[Musique]
donc atteint
dans cet immense sanctuaire de 800
hectares tout au nord de la namibie
une trentaine de rescapés se réveille
tout doucement
[Musique]
quand les apps et hershey n'entre dans
l'enclos tous les guépards savent qu'il
est l'heure de manger et de faire un peu
de sport
allez les filles il faut les maintenir
en forme
même ici en captivité
ça va là c'est celle qui court le plus
vite
[Musique]
six femelles ici de différents âges et
tous
les vétérinaires et les soigneurs comme
léa et c'est de leur offrir ici une vie
paisible loin des mauvais traitements
qu'ils ont subis so savannah ne sache
savannah et sasha était chez quelqu'un
comme animal de compagnie rainbow on la
trouvait sur le bord d'une route quand
elle était toute petite et marisa elle a
été capturée par un fermier on l'a eue
l'an dernier elles ont toutes des
parcours différents
savannah sacha et les autres sont des
survivantes de leur espèce en un siècle
la population de guépard a diminué de
90%
en 1900 on en comptait plus de 100
milles dans le monde aujourd'hui il en
reste environ 7000 dont la moitié en
namibie
les guépards sont vraiment très grand
danger je pense et le problème ici ce
sont les fermiers qui n'arrivent pas à
vivre avec eux alors ils les tuent il
faut juste qu'on trouve un moyen de
cohabiter avec les animaux sauvages
pour éviter ces confrontations justement
entre fermiers et guépards le sanctuaire
a mis en place un programme unique il
dresse ses petites boules de poils des
berger d'anatolie
ils vont protéger les troupeaux de
chèvres et de moutons des attaques de
guépard
on met les chiots avec le troupeau dès
qu'ils ont un mois comme si on crée un
lien entre eux et les chèvres une fois
adulte les chiens sont vendus aux
fermiers locaux car les guépards ont
peur des chiens et préfèrent les éviter
à tout prix
le centre on a déjà vendu plus de six
ans dans tout le pays
l'un d'entre eux vit ici avec ahmad
chafic à
chaque jour l'éleveur emmène ses chèvres
en pleine brousse et il le sait un
guépard peut surgir à tout moment
mais son chien est aujourd'hui devenu
son meilleur allié
le chien made à détecter les prédateurs
dans la savane en repérant leurs odeurs
et en les faisant fuir grâce à lui je
n'aurais jamais besoin de tuer un
guépard jamais
petit à petit le sanctuaire atteint son
objectif réconcilier les hommes et les
animaux sauvages
mais pour ça il faut aussi sensibiliser
les générations de demain
à l'époque les gens tirer à vue sur les
guépards parce qu'ils avaient peur pour
le bétail ces collégiens namibiens ont
fait des centaines de kilomètres pour
découvrir la vie des guépards ici ils
apprennent à ne pas les voir comme une
menace
c'est l'une des manières de protéger les
guépards et d'éviter qu'ils ne
disparaissent ils font vraiment un super
boulot
la majorité des guépards du centre sont
relâchés dans la nature après avoir été
soignés mais les plus faibles sont
condamnés à finir leur vie dans cette
prison dorée
depuis 1991 le sanctuaire à sauver 300
félins une goutte d'eau à l'échelle
mondiale
l'animal le plus rapide du monde reste
plus que jamais menacée d'extinction